hello and welcome to this video this is
porridge of round let me think about it
round three rights of London chess
classics okay so let's have a look at
the five games and I can right away tell
you that this round was a bit more
interesting and exciting than the one
before which is not a big feet round two
was a bit of a bit of a boring one but
yeah we had some interesting games this
round ok I'm going to start with them
with the least interesting game to be
honest and go through that really
quickly because we have much to cover in
the other games so Adams Aronian was an
entire Marshall with a four and
something that could have been predicted
before the road and in fact we have we
did that correctly we mean some
Grandmaster last boo Hansen and and and
me I went on the air for icc yesterday
to cover the round together with him and
we had this guess right here that we had
an entire marshal ok be 4d 46 and now
the trade here this is a line that
aronian has played quite a bit in in
recent years and he has an excellent
score with it winning a couple of games
he only lost one game I think to Magnus
Carlsen once where he also was better
but screwed it up later so um it's very
safe choice for Adams but not very
enterprising that same and so aronian is
very comfortable in this position I had
some maneuvers here and both sides have
good squares on c5 and we had some
trades coming now be three was
interesting Black is getting rid of that
be porn and in the process also
exchanges the sea pond so that when this
is gone the night would have a good post
here on d4
yeah we had some for the traits root key
to activating the rook I've got direct
the exchange and here we have a
situation where that pawn is weak but
this is having part also is weak yeah
both ports that week but white bones
also there be two we have a couple of
very logical move this as a text and
black counter-attack say those two
weaknesses they cancel each other out
yeah if white um now grabs on a6 rugae
to its them getting this pawn back white
has no way to cover it something like
this check its yeah not doing any good
long-term plugins has this coming and
you will win that pawn so we had those
pawns traded entire draw was agreed yeah
that was a yeah very boring game but I
have to cover it yeah it's a complete
round recap so the other ones were much
more exciting so let's go to see caruana
Nakamura next the u.s. dual number one
against number two very close call they
have almost identical rating six points
difference so we get Berlin defense okay
that's not good in terms of excitement
usually but this game was actually quite
interesting and I can tell you right
away we have two more balloons in this
round but they also were interesting so
it's not always going to be boring with
this opening so let's see what happened
come on I went 43 year what's the
endgame this time it's a he he switches
lines he plays both the castles and d3
this time hd3 and he goes for for this
kind of structure it's a little bit like
them rua no pass exchange but the
difference is that in the
change variation of the Ray with a six
Bishop c6 there quite often white opens
up the center and then try to play for
an endgame and here it's a little bit
different the center is closed and why
does here trying to get to a longer
longer term maneuvering battle where the
nights are not that bad because the
position is karai the closed and blacks
pawn structure with the double porn it's
no big issue in terms of pawn weakness
but in terms of flexibility black is a
little bit less flexible with this poem
play due to the two points doubled and
so we have this or looking very very
logical and now Nakamura places b5 move
this was surprising to me during the
broadcast I felt that this looks yeah I
mean this is somewhat weakening but also
if black has to try to untangle somehow
night on this seven is blocking this
Bishop so he went for that regrouping
however we have to say that in this
position white fields them ya think a
little bit better White has this e four
square that he might be able to use and
it's not so clear what some blacks
compensation is formed for that problem
and he went nine thirty seven that's a
movie actually questioned a little bit
during the broadcast because um they
also was an alternative to go yeah 95 or
not yeah not and yet committing the
night to a particular square this this
feels somewhat passive 92b should be
four and back in now 94 yeah and this
already looks a little bit uncomfortable
why it has this very nice square and
black has a hard time to challenge the
night for example if he goes and I'd
have six it would be a big a big mistake
then Bishop g5 is
exceptionally annoying for black
something like this for example oops
something like this is completely
unplayable now white will cast a long
and go probably yeah win material here
alrighty queen age six coming it's
sloppy here with my arrows so a very
nice position for white 9006 is a yeah
pretty pretty gross mistake so um what
should like do it's not so clear the
computers recommend and this kind of
move but wyd also has this idiom this is
a very annoying looking move for the
human player the computers are not so
convinced but it is quite a problem for
black if he takes with the pawn bishop
age six is going to win material as
Queen g4 as a maid thread and the
exchange on aveda zone is attacked so
90s probably and then Bishop g5 and
something like that is somewhat yeah
uncomfortable to play white for example
has a move like this after which black
shouldn't take as this is really really
bad yeah this is weak everything's week
on black spot and white has a very easy
game route h5 and so on so check King
here and now maybe something like this I
don't know it doesn't look very
comfortable for black it is given as
equal by the computers but I completely
understand that human player wouldn't
want to go for that it's not easy to
play now camera went form some active
defense with before but this actually
can gives many weaknesses behind like
here and why not took this should be
three and we see a great night and both
pawns on the C file are weak and so
Caruana has a pretty substantial
advantage and while we were covering
this and we both thought that why should
win this somehow even though um it is
not super clear cut how this should be
done in yeah
Queens betrayal and white is still that
porn up but how to win exactly not so
easy I can if you a couple of ideas
because the way nucka wanna is playing
it a lot services vanjess is actually
dwindling away here after 95 for example
he went bishop d to replace it in a
somewhat in a very slow way which had
looked okay at first but um the the way
the game turned out it wasn't so
convincing here for example Bishop
detour that said it's what he play and
this is it should indeed slow you can
question if he may be should start with
Roxy for or Luke situ or something like
that um and and wait with this Bishop
move if he wants to make it in the first
place it's not so clear that black is
actually threatening to take this i mean
if y let's say plays a move like that i
think black would i ever take attempt to
straighten the pawn structure and and
now why'd you go kingi to so it's not so
clear why we need bishop d2 here in this
position okay it was played and now
Bishop f8 g3 again a very slow move I
was expecting before here in this
position even though I have to admit
that um yeah while white is better after
before it's still not super clear might
be success I counter-attack on that pond
and it is it is not it is not super
convincing and for example what the
engine is giving is we should be three
which is very difficult move to consider
yeah seeing that white had just dropped
back to the two yeah so it's a bit of a
stretch to think of that as a human
player yeah this is the the line that
the engine is giving with a pretty
substantial advantage too wide yeah we
have to agree but it's also quite likely
that we get some kind of root can't game
and those have a big drawing margin it's
an I think however better than what was
played in the game the way it turned out
here my camera got in a five and a four
and this makes be to a permanent target
and he got some counter play yeah look
here rukia and all of a sudden black
fields relatively active and he however
is a critical position again um we
expected rookie one in the broadcast as
an next move maybe trying to put the
bishop back to have discovered and kind
of reorganize the position we ever found
this funny move and it's very
interesting black can sacrifice the
rupiah on a double check however when we
looked at this during the broadcast we
saw a couple of honey lines and thought
that white should avoid that for example
there was a woman okay this is a chant
really bad play on white spot check mate
it's so funny to see yeah we saw lines
like that and we sort of dismiss rookie
one because of the route d3 sacrifice
however if you look at this with an
engine it just gives this and white is
better I think this is pretty much yeah
there's no question that white isn't it
a lot better here even though it's not
clear if it wins yeah for example 94
seems to be the the toughest defense and
take stakes and yeah okay why this
better but but are you winning that is
not not that easy black rook see one for
example looks looks tempting activating
the rook yeah and black here for example
Kingo c5 and just just jettison that
pawn so that he's getting rid of his
dark squared bishop something like this
it's not entirely clear if white will
ultimately win this game he is better
everything's good but do you win not
easy so it was always difficult for Kara
wanna to play because all lines are
somewhat
for you but what exactly is the best
yeah it's a continued for a while there
was just one particular moment where I
think Kara wanna could have improved and
this is the here he went king d to both
sides didn't have much much time left
and instead rookie three it was still
promising some chances trying to
activate the rook like that it's a bit
surprising that he didn't go for that
because I think it's a clear improvement
of the of the rook position to try to go
to your form and king d to felt a little
bit like waiting move something like
that I'm here Bishop c5 and rookie force
a logical way to continue and if black
wants to avoid that loss of the a 4.4
nothing has to go here after which
however we get to the c6 pawn so
something like that much and here why
this is quite a bit better now and
that's good chances to win still so that
term the game is a little bit like a
series of ya missed opportunities maybe
by Caruana and here the worst is over
for black it's important to understand
that this was played here and I'll just
check here it's important to understand
that rook takes h5 it's not a good idea
this rook is now completely off side
yeah something like this for example
intending book be to black is
essentially playing a roux cup yeah it
takes the engines and by the way quite a
while to recognize how bad this is
because the computer is not thinking in
terms of okay this is never going to get
out it just calculate stuff but black is
of course yeah black back should be in
this position it's not there shouldn't
even be a draw um just so they repeat
the chance like that and drew the game
so somewhat unfortunate and for the game
forum um for Caruana but tough defense
also Nakamura
sparty really got got himself into some
trouble but defended very tenacious Lee
and at the end got rewarded bye-bye them
by a draw okay next game will be gooey
show Geary and we've got again a
building yeah but interesting we get the
typical Berlin Wall end game and now
it's set up with age violence try it out
and what Giri is doing here is something
that I haven't seen yet in the in the
Berlin which okay might be due to my
lack of knowledge but still that that
idea without pretty pretty unique to me
Bishop g5 see 593 and now Bishop
yourself this is the idea that i'm
talking about he fianchetto with the
bishop and just hacked this night off
interesting them consequences that this
light now looks yeah like a very strong
piece it's a completely unassailable by
any pawn so that's nice but we should
have one precise a problem with black
rider threatening those night jumps and
it's difficult to allow i mean you have
to go see six there is no other way 95
cannot be allowed and this on the other
hand of course beacons d6 quite a bit so
very interesting position Bishop e7 f4
takes takes King yourself or played
relatively quickly up to this point but
both players um it's tough to say I have
a hard time to evaluate this position
but the way it turned out there 96 was
playing to King e6 and now f4 x am by
beggary shock it turned out that black
was in some trouble on the other hand we
have to take a look at the clock times
yeah one hour 34 geary and goo shock I'm
not quite sure that this is correct but
it was down to a couple of
it's I think well I wouldn't bet bet big
money on that but i think it was between
like five and seven minutes a relay here
sometimes isn't 100-percent precise but
Grisha really wasn't charm trouble and
there's no incremented that's that
tournament so and something to keep in
mind yeah Ruby aid was played and it's
possible that this leads to yet to that
big trouble that I was talking about
maybe he had to really just take this
and and go flat this type of position
it's it's hard to tell exactly what this
is how to evaluate this lie group t7 is
going to be played and black probably
goes rogue f8 then gang 48 it's it's
tough to evaluate but probably black has
to do it I mean it's tough to evaluate
means I think it's better than the game
that that's pretty much clear but it's
hard to tell if it's equal or what what
exactly to make of it this is definitely
bad for black because after Luke you one
now black if a black gets too late now
to take this is the important thing now
the pawn captures and something like
this it's a is unplayable for black
white pony is far too strong if black
takes here and we've got h4 and later
rupee seven coming that that's just not
not going to be a be playable for black
so you went g6 and now is entirely
passive my black cannot take on d6 this
didn't feel very successful while white
can improve pretty easily even with no
time where you can play that quite
comfortably asics looks pretty awful but
it's difficult to give black any advice
the thing is that white also threatened
a five and here a five let's say
ya hear a five can be answered by B 5
and this is what he wanted to prepare on
the other hand this is of course weekend
um it's just a choice between various
evils that black has to has to make this
is what he tried you know and now taking
the pawn yeah here we come to a critical
situation I think night x is six now
would have been close to winning for
gree shock one thing is that this is
leading channel to a lost night end game
and upon CR are too weak and this is
also a completely dominating position
where black has a hard time to improve
this pieces serve in any meaningful way
let's say night f5 for example it goes
here so you have this regrouping and
complete control it's just an
overwhelming position for for white yeah
96 was stronger Roxy six is also not
terribly bad or so yeah i mean the white
keeps her keeps the keeps a pool but it
gives black some more hope definitely
and one thing we see is this a very nice
move here by bacteria to try to defend
this position I think now after the next
move on we shook now takes with the pawn
it's probably um probably a draw um the
toughest it seems to be was Rupert
Brooke c7 check even though it's not
entirely clear if this is going to be
enough to win the game Black has this
couch today and the important thing is
he will get this pawn very likely kingi
to it's just too passive NFU if you go
up this age pawn will prove to be quite
the dangerous asset it's not quickly i
played around a little bit with this and
in most cases black marriage to draw not
not one hundred percent sure but it
seems that black should be okay yeah
this happened check HERE blacks counter
place definitely enough one thing is
that check HERE probably agree shocked I
mean we have to take into account that
he was down to a couple of seconds he
maybe didn't didn't see 98 before and
when he was angling towards this in 98
is a very nice defensive move now
trading off that fantastic night yeah
this is a blunder so why it has to
accept this and check here black has
enough counter play mean is a pawn up at
the moment but the important thing is
that he's got yeah lots of activity wyd
no went f5 and after that they had made
the draw here with the with the checks
um if white takes on g6 black can check
here and enter and this also is
something that blacks should never lose
equal material and we get we get things
here so on a draw at the end curious
notoriously difficult to bj he hasn't
lost a single game yet on the the grand
chester and this is a pretty impressive
feat yeah over more than 20 games now
against this this opposition a bit lucky
here we should already had outplayed him
quite nicely but yeah if you defend in a
tenacious where you sometimes get
rewarded by met those kind of results
okay let's have a look at the duel of
the world champions now ananth cards and
world champion 15 vishy anand against
number 16 Magnus cars so it's again you
know thank you know put the puddin but I
can promise you that we had some
interesting points there so maybe she is
going going on the endgame
this is our plate yeah there are a
couple of deviations of course along the
way and I don't want to make a survey of
this of this opening but the interesting
point comes here this is already a
somewhat rare position there are many
alternatives before but this is already
somewhat somewhat rare thing is that now
Bishop c5 was played by by Magnus and
this idea is was completely unknown to
him to both the last Bronson and yours
truly never saw that idea in the Berlin
just put the Bishop to c5 normally
blacks Black is going for a setup where
the bishop comes to e7 or sometimes even
the night we'll regroup and only then
you go to e7 but going to see 5 or
something that we that didn't have on
our Raiders at all yeah and are not no
place in a very principled fashion yeah
gaining space on the Kings side this is
also one of the reasons for this
somewhat mysterious h3 move earlier this
move here you prepared you for 97 back
that is not possible of course yeah as
the I mean it's possible all the time
but here it's a plane in a situation
where the bishop is not buried on f8 but
out in the open on c5 night here you're
taking that Bishop and Bishop t5 if
black um wants the black black only
wants to give up the bishop um if it's
pawn structure gets straightened out of
course why does not taking on d5 but
goes with this the night comes to e-form
gaining a tempo Bishop back to be 6 that
was the idea and now kingi to the idea
of King g2 is that after a possible age
5 you want that King to protect routed
squares and also you want to be ready to
bring the f porn into the game and want
to get out of this day
so that there is no pin on the f porn
group 28 Bishop f4 yeah first developing
the bishop here and later push with
their form very logical let's say cause
of the game and cards not traded and
here he surprised us by going King to e7
we absolutely had reckoned with this
move because we thought that this amid
forces on the capture on h4 white cannot
remove the king this is a check can lead
to some embarrassing situations here for
example this is a funny line 92 chattox
Teague's ain't no Knight f5 very
embarrassing threatening night III check
and winning the rook Andrew cage one
with the gannets almost a mate but to
win the rukon d1 ya hear why this just
lost amazing something like this is
going to check happen and this is a
pretty funny example why bishops are
stronger than nights in many cases
amazing position yeah so white
absolutely has to take this and then we
expected this line and ya know maybe
Luke h1 not quite clear if we want to do
this but something like that that was um
an hour our radar and we thought that
blank is okay and I think we were right
Black is okay um the line that Carlton
plate was a little bit different you
played kini seven here but now Luke age
one white was quicker on let's say quick
on the edge file so that night h4 check
is not on and now black has to take a
five into account and the night doesn't
have such a great square he played this
yeah the idea said after m5 this is
going to win so white has to react to
that oops chand to Gandhi five maybe
cause an underestimated that move it's
not not quite clear what
what TM exactly what i was thinking in
this situation however we felt that
black has some problems to solve
especially in regards to a possible 92
let's say if what black goes for
something like that then 92 is a pretty
annoying move you cannot take on b2 as
Ruby one is pretty awkward yeah it's
that same ticks ticks and ticks ticks
and here after rook t7 ruby three is
pretty pretty bad and you have no good
square for that Bishop something like
this it's downright awful where do you
want to go with the noid back to have 8
j blacks position is a complete mess
here um it turns out that 92 is very
annoying so he captured on c3 politics
and King this out you're getting a
square for this it's a funny line years
if black tries to trade down the roofs
and then this is flat-out winning it's a
funny position with the night yet yeah
f6 e6 and this is completely completely
off so that was no good idea and he went
Kingda seventh giving some space here
father for the night so f5 must plate 97
rookie one here king of three and around
here we thought that maybe a why does a
little bit better but it didn't really
materialize so Carson attacked this pawn
two times and white had to protect and
now he played a very nice move g5 move
that I couldn't really I at first that I
was surprised about it because it's a
little bit uncommon that you would put a
pawn on a dark square and especially in
a case where it is almost fixed on g5
the pawn will never move
there and it's uncommon to put upon
there when the other side has a dark
squared bishop but that kind of
regrouping I like a bishop coming over
to d2 and attack that pawn and it's
simply not possible in this position as
if I've is always under attack in
general White has that problem now he
needs to have those two pieces cavity
higher and this probably means that we
are talking about it an equal position
why Cannot Mukhlis pieces and black also
has a hard time to improve however
there's something interesting happening
a little bit later and this is coming
here they both made yeah some somewhat
shuffling type moves yeah and tiana
definitely should continue with the
shuffle king f3 and it's very likely
actually that they would have drawn them
because there is no way forward for for
black trying to improve and white also
he has to shuffle with this cover only
50 v5 being mandatory all of the time
what he did is he played this move and
it's not quite clear why exactly wired
to do this instead of King a3 because
there is no big active idea let's say
connected with the move so um it feels
like a shuffling move but it's actually
not a very good shuffling move as now
Knight a5 is possible and the night will
come to c4 in this situation Knight a5
is no good due to this and black having
released the pressure on e5 he has
allowed way to enter this is something
that black probably shouldn't do after
rookie 3 or Evan Knight a5 is something
that black is happily playing as the
night is just more active now and this
does the same job on c4 as it was doing
from c6 attacking that porn so king of
three Kingdon and now a five yeah what's
the idea of a five that pawn on e4 is
fixed
and with c6 and b5 black gets to make
progress on the queenside and this is
very serious business now if we get an a
pawn that's going to be a dangerous pass
on unplayed group to be one here and
certainly being aware that he yeah made
some some bad decision just sorry bad
decisions earlier yeah now is the
critical position Carlton has to make
one more move he's got about 16 to 17
minutes left on the clock and in this
particular position and he had to take
his chance there night takes d5 now was
very strong it's not clear if it wins
but it seems that black has good winning
chances with this move a takes b5 i
guess and night takes just taking pawns
they're important point is that if white
tries to promote the beep on that this
is not how analog hear something like 93
check chat something like a like this
for example black can easily give up the
exchange as here oops sorry this is of
course check having like it like a
million of porns there are 33 points and
this is also falling so that's
absolutely no good for white it's
difficult are able to give white some
advice probably tougher is king f3 after
which black l can go nite h6 and attack
this pawn yeah it's it's not clear if
this is holding for what for example um
if white pushes this pawn in 95 yeah
it's just better for black but what can
you do he's material up and this is not
a CLIA counterplay I'm like this and we
take and here the king is stopping the
pawn does this in particular should just
win for black 9085 was a huge
opportunity however cards after a long
thing played rook h eight and this this
move was very irritating well
my commentating Grandmaster colleague
and me I have no idea what this move was
doing it was really completely
mysterious to us if you don't take e5
why exactly go 2 h8 why not let's say go
to a 8 where you at least kind of
support the a pawn it's really not not
clear what this is doing yeah I not now
played bishop f2 he took this
opportunity to activate the bishop may
be getting it here or to c5 and it seems
that I'm now the worst is over for white
car took the power now and it's clear
that in comparisons must be a lot worse
than with the Lucani ehm 8x b5 hand I
g-form check check and here we already
see that white has activated quite a lot
and this move will also help the rook to
get active the bishop is also now in a
somewhat dominating position against
this night ruki 8 check again and now
wyd was active enough yeah there were
various possibilities but it is all
going to end in a draw check and
side-chain child is getting down those
pawns can also be completely traded off
think they're here already yeah here
they agree to a draw so that was a
somewhat lucky draw for vision on that
possibility of 9085 here not xt5 was a
big chance for four cards but he seems
that he's not quite yet out of his bad
bad form that he had in the recent month
I think it's pretty much unthinkable
that the cars and in top shape would let
this let this opportunity slip okay we
have one game left and this is MBL with
white against Apollo two part of the
only player in this event
lost the game in the round in the first
round against Giri when he fell for some
technical visitor ebuyer by the dutch
player when he was short on time give me
found a nice idea and topple off didn't
didn't spot the point and lost so he
badly needs some some results because I
mean in the grand chest or overall
standings to parlor with the leading um
by one or two points just just very very
narrow lead so he definitely needs a
good result in this event to to get
something going in the overall standings
so we get a night off it was kind of
expected they are both night off
specialists and very principled players
and the French number one year goes for
age three it's a good interesting
sideline that in recent years has gotten
more and more popular it also shows a
little bit that the main line neither
wars are not that successful for Wyatt
h3 has one particular sorry one
particular idea and this is g4 or Bishop
e3 in some cases there should be three
as now prepared as g4s covered but the
main idea is to push g4 yeah in many
cases this is them the key IDM okay e
five was played and dropped back and now
if black plays on routine move like
Bishop e7 then white will oops right
we'll go g4 then Bishop g2 and try to
gain even more space on the King side
while maintaining some control over t5
this is why this move has become
fashionable Black is just using this
this tempo to prevent g4 very modern
approach to this position g3 night bt7
Bishop g2 be five in 95 yeah we have a
structure pretty typical of many
Sicilian lines like that specially cough
the night off in some cases the
kalashnikov like
set um weakness on d5 that square
weakness but as we will see and he's got
a good piece position let's go forward a
little bit with night and be sure and
they both look at the square so there is
no danger that white is going to occupy
d5 with the piece and establish a piece
they are long term if why does putting a
piece then the porn will appear on
defined this is usually not that
dangerous we see that scenario in the
game and why displaying a four and puts
the night to d5 here black Hansen's
choice you can take with both pieces 95
and bishop t5 we were more expecting
bishop t5 and this kind of thing maybe
then 9725 but caparros choice is
perfectly fine it took with the night
and when day five you are covering this
before square Paul I'm sorry yeah now
Queenie to was played attacking
attacking the h5 pawn this is of course
now slide weakness that pawn move early
on is somewhat but it's a committal move
yeah it's nothing that can be fixed
later let's say and it turns out that
tapado has a technical solution for this
problem he does not have to cover that
pawn if Y now takes on age five and it's
getting into huge trouble this is
something that you don't want to see the
rook we are getting very active here so
he took on g5 first and now played age
four and that's a much better choice
between decks h5 really was just a
mistake here we would have been just a
mistake here we expected Queenie 7 to
happen the idea is that we wanted to
cover that bishop so that after Queen B
five black has this easy move rube c5
this is hang but again we felt that this
is not so dangerous black can just
continue with this play yeah like here
and put
on that pond and it doesn't seem to be
very dangerous for black he said porn
down but his play is pretty substantial
note that this is not a good idea okay
now it it appears the arrows h7 is
checkmate and the rook is hanging so not
a good idea and two part of plate Queen
f6 so ever I mean this is also good
Queenie 7 let's say our movie wasn't bad
but this is also quite okay the idea is
that now critics h5 is downright bad due
to this with this pawn attacked and this
point attacked and Bishop before now
there's just g6 yeah because there is no
sacrifice now on g6 the queen is
protecting this and yeah why this just
in terrible champion so what did you do
he played Queen B 5 this is the far more
critical move Queenie 7 now back and
takes so what is the counter play black
gets his pawn and gets pretty active
rukon see to an important point is that
now if why it takes on before you played
this one but if white takes on before
then black also has good play the only
thing that you should is to do is avoid
this move this is what we thought during
the broadcast but this is a mistake uxie
one rogue f2 there is screen b6 with a
nice double attack and blackest losing
material the black has no problems
whatsoever he should just play this move
Queen over here coverings he wants a
look-see one is not happening and black
has enough active play now he still has
this idea or sometimes just bring the
rook over he would definitely get a pawn
back with a very decent position this
was played and here to pile of him had
he had calculated this very precisely
rook takes me to was possible now
the thing is that the move rooks is
seven which looks great in the first
place or the first look is actually
rather bad because of Queen here and
this is a pretty awful oops oops pretty
awful pin of the rook white cannot move
the Queen now and the rook is also yeah
in mobile it's just a very bad idea for
what so Luke c7 is bad and he played
rugby one instead you are making sure
that we get the pawn okay black when
Drew gay to and queen before and Bishop
86 and now queen bee three in critical
moment now it seems that here to par
love had an active possibility and the
computer wants to play rook t2 just
keeping the rook on the board an
important point is that after lucrative
one your black can take which is ok but
he also has an additional interesting
possibility this move it first it looks
pretty crazy because again we have this
tactic but black in fact can capture
here and play the bishop back to c8 and
that position is surprisingly difficult
to play for white there is this idea 27
in 3h 6 and also there's fr therefore
and all of a sudden White's King feels
extremely shaky that line I think would
have been yeah completely and never been
to Palos taste for sure I had this kind
of active play but it seems that he
didn't didn't see this possibility and
he went for Bishop f1 this is not
necessarily so bad but the alternative
just seems just seems stronger wind
takes on a two and now he captured on g2
we found that Bishop d3 is better
keeping this on also to keep some kind
of eye on there is six squares and the a
porn cannot run up the board so quickly
idea also would be e for later it's
maybe better but I think the real issue
is coming here here White has the
easier game with the apron but if black
now goes for immediate count to play
with you for it still might be a might
be enough to draw this might be it's not
so not easy at all but it seems stronger
than what you did the idea is to of
course just push all the way to e3 and
get it white somewhat weakened King we
will see the difference to the game I
think pretty a pretty clearly if white
now plays let's say rook to be 62 I
check this pawn then black has Queenie 5
or f5 both Muslim come into
consideration also the immediate III is
interesting as well coming with Queenie
for him yeah in any case this is a
better counter play than in the game in
the game view when Drew k 8 and now a 5
was played efore and ruby three and this
is the big public problem now you're not
getting to e3 the rook is covering that
and the apron already is pretty pretty
quick f5 after this it's probably over
for black probably yes it's not it's not
clear that other moves still safe but f5
seems to be a to weakening Queenie 5 is
a probably a bit tough of it it is very
difficult to give black advice here the
a porn it's very dangerous Queen d2 now
played by mvl he covers those square so
that there's no counter play coming the
engine is very fearless and wants to go
a6 probably a computer is right as usual
in such a forcing position something
like this for example and looks indeed
winning black doesn't have something
seriously I can just give one check and
here it's basically over this would be 8
coming and there are no good way to
prevent that ok King h7 as possible
there are some ideas with counter play
but note that this is also pretty big
problem and yeah this was played that is
not so powerful
in comparison and Quincy cell Queen B to
intending would be seven quite clearly
and tier Queen takes f5 still continued
the game a little bit it'sit's looks
pretty awkward check but at least here
white has to trade Queens and we get to
a rogue endgame I mean black is probably
losing this as well but yeah you can
continue the game after this group b
seven it is unfortunately for tomorrow
it's over Brooke eight when Queen B 5
and here black has absolutely no way to
save himself and Quincy one for example
there's create check and this and
something like this is downright
downright awful like as a pawn down all
remaining pawns are weak and this king
is bad in no counter play that is still
lost hey tried this move which is like
pure panic but check had to resign after
Queenie to as blackest out of any
meaningful checks you can give some more
check but that's it yeah or maybe and
maybe like two or so but Chang
ultimately it will be be over with the
revenge checks of spy checks so a second
loss for Apollo who again reacted
somewhat badly in in town under time
pressure it seems that is maybe it's
somewhat rusty I don't know he didn't
play in the European ER team of
championships as Bulgaria didn't
participate um I don't know it feels
like he's not quite on one hundred
percent in this event and minus two
after three rounds is pretty bad and it
means that he's almost out of the yeah
out of this competition for the overall
winner of the grand chess to as you
definitely need a good result in this
third event and from the minus to score
it doesn't feel like he's staging a big
comeback
leading up to three rounds are mvn and
on each Giri were both with plus one but
it's of course yeah all players mean
probably not to pull off but all other
players might be able to to do something
in the event yeah they're all on fifty
percent o plus one so it's a very very
tough competition and very interesting
event overall we had a good round this
round three and let's hope that the
coming rounds will be just as
interesting hope you enjoyed the
coverage and now be back tomorrow with
round four thanks for watching